[Music]
and we're always being told that we need
to catch up perfectly there because they
have the best division of systems and
control but I guess the only consolation
can get the business that Professor
Thomas occurs in fact an MIT graduate so
he'll be talking to us about
mechatronics of y2k status reform
professor Thomas recap thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
integration mechanical engineering with
electronic and intelligent computer
control in the design or manufacture of
industrial product and processes now if
we this was in 1996 but now everybody
talking about information technology if
we would have started channel maybe
instead of electronics we would have say
something information technology and
instead of computer control good I would
have put more abstract what like complex
decision-making
so therefore y2k definition made it
something like sass energetic
integration of physical systems with
information technology and complex
decision-making the other part
if you like you can still keep but it's
not that important
when we say information technology I
think you have some good definition of
Fatty's information for the information
technology but it's essentially the same
thing I'm putting some devices which
would store information and so forth
but starting from electronics
microprocessor in 1972 some Network
communication internet embedded DSPs
over home phone what I mean really by
information technology here and
decision-making site I'm referring to my
favorite area control theory design
methodology well in more recent
development in the area of hybrid system
theory and so forth so in the mainstream
of course there is a physical systems
and physical systems I see gaining one
more important importance in our life is
something like bio engineering and
medicine energy transportation or
intelligent transportation systems
environmental engineering and
manufacturing I picked up this list from
a decent publication from a SME he said
mechanical engineering in the 21st
century and it came out September 1999
Nastia it's one of a few publications
from a SME which I quite agree very much
and quasi quite useful and by the way
they they are listing 10 and of course
at the top there's something which would
make the difference in the next century
they put information technology and the
way I see is that fast 3 Morris talking
about some and what i'ma call and every
technology and here is an asked five
defining some exciting area and
mechatronics somehow come here to
synthesize and utilize a neighboring
technology in each specific domain area
to make such thing things more exciting
now so of course the driving forces of
mechatronics was I put information
technology it's making implement
mechatronics more and more exciting but
suddenly of course need from
industry and those two combined are
really introducing new ways of doing
things new pattern of syncing or people
some people prefer to call mechatronics
simply as the best practice so certainly
that best practice is evolving as a
technology develops need from industry
this is from a talk by Mike Mastin Texas
Instrument he put together general trend
in industry and not something already
said yesterday and some of the thing
which may not have been explicitly said
but I think you know most of the things
here and one thing probably it which
interesting is this team Steamworks our
preferred approach so I would comment
data but some of the courses that we
teach in this area we try to teach some
teamwork through the project work now
let me go through some recent research
at UCB with in the area of controls or
mechatronics and good part of topics
that myself and my console colleagues
but I added something which is really
relevant to information technology which
is not quite my area like cyber cut my
proselyte and some of the saga Gino's
works I think she is remember advisory
committee and she will be coming
tomorrow now the area of computer disk
drives this research is conducted in the
computer mechanics laboratory and it's a
consortium of industrial consortium and
in the controls area myself and for
solids have been looking into this area
and to really to answer to the need from
the hard disk industries they are
striving for higher density storage
faster seek time and of course roaring
cost if we look at some schematic what's
going on there are two types of problem
and one is so-called track for
that recording head has to stay on that
data track and I think it's supposed to
be Saku but it's not quite very some
random error while in case of removable
storage devices there might be some
eccentricity and they're also going on
but some recent work is one of my
student finishing in the area control
this is a methodology which deals with
periodic disturbances and very positive
control is ideally suited for this type
of problem because this crease speeding
at some fixed speed so the same pattern
appears many times so it's essentially
how you may drop sensitivity to almost
to zero at certain frequencies the
described industry use so-called 6r
drive sector drive is that circular disk
we sliced into the area and so-called
position information is not written only
at the boundary so you would like to
keep a number of sectors small so you
have most area for storing data but
sometimes that you cannot get enough
some frequencies measurement frequency
or doing some fine control now instead
of having sectors and putting more
informations there has been some work to
increase some effective bandwidth by
updating the input more frequent than
the measurement frequencies and that's
called multi rate control and it's a
very interesting area both from control
point of view and for this type of
application point of view and another
student is finishing her PhD in this
case she in this area and also the
traditional disk size that you find in a
computer has got only one actuator voice
coil motor but everybody is now working
on how you can introduce second stage
actuator essentially you put more
freedom so for fine motion control and
the next the immediately fat
coming out well in the market is among
utilizing piezo electric piezo
transducer and suddenly we are working
in this area also my colleague Horovitz
in collaboration with Sun of how they're
really MEMS faculty member is looking
into the next generation
second stage actuator by utilizing MEMS
technology and this one is sponsored by
DARPA and they are working with IBM so
this is the rotary type actuators a
design both rotary type actuator and
linear actuator to point mimetic
diameter and they have already closed
group and they have got the basic
performance one area I'm noting with how
it is an NSF War II project with Xerox
Corporation for making the paper hunting
part of the copying machines more
reliable and more intelligent and it's
really a mechatronics product and we are
suggesting to introduce an mechatronics
thinking in the product design so we are
looking into some new ways of handling
papers in the copying machine
traditional machine essentially you can
think about that there has got one big
conveyor belt paper is fed from one end
and go to the image transfer station and
there is some control going on but from
here to there there is essentially no
control open-loop control so as a result
the program you experience is so-called
soft Jam for hard jams when does a
measurement station they are checking
whether as a paper is present or not
if the paper does not come as I expected
moment the computer our controller
thinks that something went wrong and
simply stops the machine and even though
the paper may not be jamming but
software found Jam so it called software
Jam and we are trying to
make it better at least remove software
Jam by breaking up the conveyor the
conveyor into several sections and add
sensor and actuator at each stage
certainly this will complicate the
problem and if you have many sense and
actuators if you do not have good way of
deciding the control option this is not
a kind of scheme that you'd like to
employ but with some power of the
computer now this is quite feasible and
so we are looking into this problem
still we have to do some economic
constellation so what will be the
required number of actuate and sensors
we cannot just add too many from cost
point of view also and also reliability
and maintenance and also the program
itself is quite interesting because
paper is moving and there are lots of
constraint generated when paper is
handed from one station to another you
do not want to bark or you do not want
to stretch because you might end up
adding some marks and also if you
purpose is to essentially control the
distance from one paper to another so if
it's too close we would like to increase
the separation but there is only a
limited time window that you can apply
control feedback control so it turns out
to be a nice example of the hybrid
system discrete event systems and
integer if quite it's a very quite
challenging most of the things we do we
would like to do experimental check
otherwise people won't believe us but
also by working on their hardware we
find lots of interesting problems so in
this case we got part from Xerox and we
made some top desktop paper pass and it
has got essentially three parts each
part can be independently controlled and
of course we have some paper feeder and
I can either go around for many times
where we have some exit gate that
controls so paper can come out this is a
motor and measurement at this stage is a
motor measurement and also Laura is very
physically cam moving the paper but we
are measuring the position of the Laura
it's best to measure of where paper is
and also if we can measure of a paper
velocity so we are also adding photo
sensor to detect the position and
velocity of the paper
California has got a past program it's a
very big program first and for partners
for advanced transit and highways it
started in 1986 and there are also
interesting control problems in the past
area in particular advanced vehicle
control and safety systems it's a lot of
interesting control problem for
mechanical engineering student
mechanical engineers ahead Erick nay
former faculty at MIT and myself have
been working a lot in this area and
especially from automated driving AHS
point of view in 1980s
97 we had a high point of path walk this
was a slide from the 1997 national
automated highway systems consortium
demo done in San Diego and essentially
past walk beside market pass resulted
into the demo by eight car platoon so
eight car is making some sort of saying
operation they have very tight
longitudinal control and tressa
hedrick's each block really resulted in
doing this tight longitudinal control my
group has been working on automated
steering for
many years and that we have doing this
demo essentially what we do is we put
magnet in the middle of the Lord magnet
is about four feet apart and
magnetometer sensed distance and then
steering action is figured out by
computer so it's completely hands-free
driving he's putting hand and now after
this demo of course the core national
consortium was disbanded discontinued
but now the California is continuing
this automating high rate effort with
emphasis on these heavy vehicles so I'm
currently working with my graduate
student on the automated steering for
this truck this is Fred Reiner that in
fact this is our current tests truck
some magnet technology has been shifted
applied to some of the maintenance road
maintenance work by Caltrans people
California Department of Transportation
we have some snow countries and they
have got the idea to put magnet and do
some guide vehicle Wow for the
maintenance operation for safe
maintenance operation they are not
immediately interested in automating the
operation but try to come up with some
way of assisting the human driver when
you are removing the snow when the wind
blows there is so-called white out
conditions generated driving
instantaneously good site so in that
case how the magnet information combined
with some dynamic fluid prediction of
where as a vehicle may be going may be
displayed on the screen so the driver
can easily detect why you can even can
drive looking at the screen it's an
interesting man machine interface design
program because you'd like to see that
driver be not confused by looking at
screen he should be able to switch back
and forth and still maintain some
Souness operation and one student is
finishing PhD currently on this subject
so this is a typical application this is
not snow plow
this is no blower and in case of snow
blower Caltrans
interested in control even automated
driving so we are starting that project
the causal reasoning process occurs
early he's a graduate of MIT also he has
been working on the combination of the
human intelligence and power available
from hardware devices he has been
quoting extenders he joined us from
Minnesota six probably five six years
ago and this is a device he designed at
a Minnesota but it's a very early
version of his theory making his idea of
human intelligence pass mechanical power
into some hardware device and more
recently he has been working on from arm
to leg and some of this is some of his
recent work powered or extremity
enhancer and you can see some device and
this is a recent experiment he conducted
at Berkeley and the idea is by having
this device people can carry lots of
heavy things and some battleground and
so phones by the way this is one slide
he requested me not to put on the web ok
so I I will just eliminate this slide
when when you
this is press alighted to apply Sanjay
can explain this slide much better than
I - but if if Wright has some
interesting idea now everybody is
talking about how you can make use of
the resource available at remote
locations to accomplish your job okay so
essentially networked manufacturing
service and this area is really his
activity is expanding
I think Ford Motor Company has donated
some quite a bit money to even try this
kind of thing one day
on-site education aspect now this is a
slide that I received from I've a Gugino
so I cannot add too much except it is
written down here this is hardly such
project concept database and overview
it's essentially a multimedia Network
conceptual design support tool and some
smart navigation through a hyper media
database wobbling design concept and
electronic component catalogs etc and
her present is a job research address
aspect listed here some of the things
which I personally find interesting is
to manage uncertainties in design
decision making intelligent real-time
design okay so how deal time this
network even-paced to can assist the
designer she has made some prototype
conceptual database and in fact one of
our goal here mechatronics is a very
important aspect in her research I
didn't quite mention but at the bottom
she put that domain of application is
mechatronics design so it's highly
relevant to make atronics and this is
for assisting the motifs erection so she
put lots of intelligence there now let
me just comment some educational
challenge from mechatronics point of
view and what we are doing at UC
Berkeley as far as I see it all or any
and the student should be exposed to
mechatronics thinking so for that
student needs to experience some
mechanical design information technology
and so forth to
through teamwork and but also this area
technology keeps changing so students
should be trained to be forward-looking
and curious what we provide at the
school will never be all and maybe in a
few years it's just all the stuff so
unless they have trained to be study
themselves or curious look into new
areas we are not doing the right job the
last comment is more addressed when I
give this kind of talk outside the
United States I suppose we are
everybody is using English now what is
essential in this area so we have both
undergraduate graduate courses - student
do some laboratory work often we make a
team and through that people will learn
some complexity aspect the system
aspects we are doing so several things
happens at the same time era depends on
minor changes in timing the best way to
run this type of aspect is through
actually project work
this is undergraduate course that Heath
Catherine is teaching and so if you look
at the syllabus it from some
microcontroller electronic motors and so
forth so this is covered by the lecture
but on the top of ZAP he has a project
everybody has to accomplish project by
the way when student takes this course
student has not taken necessarily
feedback control courses and we can
never underestimate the creativity of
undergraduate student without control
causes formal control causes student in
fact lots of interesting project this is
one project from last year automatic
bicycle gear shifter it's quite
innovative
and some walking robot and it walks and
to change the direction it has got some
another motor spinning so depending on
in which way multi spinning is not
making a very interesting maneuvering
this is from a course developed by
another MIT graduates in fact David as
Rhonda he has been kind of leader in the
area of introducing microcomputers to
control culture and this is a switching
control he called switching control but
essentially it's a discrete even system
many things happens and how that was a
computer system can detect which the
operation he is in in this particular
case trains going around at one point
saying motion has to be synchronized
with the motion of this conveyor sink
which is carrying some iron ball its
magnet so by on off switch magnetic and
even on this side a magnet can be
dropped or ball can be dropped so it's a
loading move some steel ball on that
same white thing is in motion so just by
doing this student can lots of
interesting aspect for real-time
programming now the graduate level of
the education I have to really say that
fundamentals input really emphasize the
fundamentals fundamentals are really
fundamental and I think we do quite a
good job in this area also now topics
for dissertation research ok this is
something quite opposite but Professor
sue was mentioning yesterday two minutes
okay so balance between theory and
application as I see it's very important
of course it doesn't have to be 50/50
split in my case I'm quite adjusted to
that type of the student so it's
customized some student innate ki
excelling theory part could be 90% and
application part could be ten well the
other way around somebody more
technology oriented I could put that in
emphasized more this aspect but I think
at some point in life especially student
life students should be exposed to boss
and of course that's related to the
research funding but we have been so far
lucky to find some exciting project for
student and especially for PhD we are I
think that least UC Berkeley our goal is
to really train future leaders both in
academia and in industry and so far we
have been quite successful when we say
fundamental essentially every aspect but
if you look at the kind of list of
courses that we are giving at the
graduate level we are very happy that we
have from both technology and to the
Surry end and especially the control
salary side we have a very good coverage
and we make it sure that we give this
kind of control theory courses every
semester it's not really a control
course is given for the curiosity of
only faculty members we are giving these
courses for students so even when
somebody goes to sabbatical we make it
sure that the course is covered this is
another aspect of probably of Education
this is outcome of a saga Geno's effort
of national coalition synthesis
coalition it's now continuing as an East
national engineering education delivery
system digital library and you can check
this on the internet so if you say
mechatronics
you can go through some of the modules
that she has developed or her group has
developed not necessarily all from
Berkeley
yes okay so let me conclude my talk by
stating that information technology add
a new dimension to mechatronics
mechatronics is essential in all the
engineering in the information age and
lifelong lifelong learning aspect is
important and so a system level thinking
and teamwork thank you very much
[Applause]
yes to me put a lot of stuff in at 25
minutes apart but you didn't mentioned
where are you guys going hmm
okay I think that we are essentially it
is going in the direction information
technology area we talked about whether
we should make something more option at
least undergraduate level there is some
divided opinion we are not quite
convinced to to make a to pass bandwidth
because as always as a department did
not come agreement some somebody always
wants to keep the way that we have been
doing and so then there's some new
people who would like to do some more
emphasis on information technology so
for required courses we once thought
about whether we might be able to make
two two versions one with some
computational information technology
sync and the other one with without just
traditional way but I think to version
idea is not a good idea so eventually
what I am thinking what I'm seeing is we
will be introducing more and more
information technology at least use a
computational sink in that education of
undergraduate education so that's
definitely happening now and also I've
mentioned the yesterday a little bit but
we are at the situation that may be
close to the Silicon Valley student
attention is very much directed to
computer science and we have to really
make a good case how mechanical
engineering will grow in that
environment so one idea which was really
discussed among the current was that
probably information technology
computational things does not have to be
taught on the all in computer science
but if we do whether we can set up an
attractive courses that we can draw a
lot of students
but at least when we are hiring new
people we are looking into what kind of
expertise new guy have so they can
naturally participate in the area of
computational engineering information
technology aspect so that's one one
thing we have been looking green to and
maybe from research point of view it's
all depends on individual faculty member
it's more about the environment
pree probably MIT is a situation must be
the same it's pretty much bottom of each
individual faculty members interest is
same and everybody sensitive so they are
introducing some new idea into the
research but we do not have any really
strategic thing except that we say that
okay we emphasized bioengineering
mechanical engineering saying that we
will emphasize bioengineering
manufacturing for long period but
bioengineering will certainly not just
mechanical engineering subject so the
courage started McKenna department of
mechanical bioengineering a few years
ago so it's a single independent
department so that does a kind of new
things happening
okay when I like TV big undergraduate
control theory course right now and
every control 3.72 if the whole reason
that the block is called the Wat is not
because what have a steam engine but
because he's been at the government with
a steam engine the governor is a simple
feedback device its goal is simply to
process information and it was the
governor that made the machine edge of a
useful tool
I think it's efficiency and power
capacity by five many factors of 10 plus
by factors of 10 200 okay so what mean
information technology has always been
in mechanical engineering and
mechatronics I think completely big
beautiful examples that we just heard it
shows you how that has blossomed as the
capacity for information processing come
from okay thanks
Purdue University and I accepted the
invitation of sneak here and then saw
the program and saw that was last so I
began to check into that and and I know
the reason now I have no connection with
MIT
actually I'm totally true I I did I did
interview here I guess you say when I
was
where to go to school for PhD with John
question business but ended up choosing
to go to do so maybe that's the school
idiot Purdue has a long history and just
to put it in context with the MIT group
we graduate a little under three hundred
students a year so we sort of graduate
the size of MIT s undergraduate program
each year so we're three or four times
that in size we have about 50 faculty
something like 300 grad students and
we've definitely begun to focus on on IT
and how that will play into our school I
think that's still a process one of the
exciting things we opportunities we have
is a professorship the Feddersen
professorship focused exactly on that
interface between Emmy and IT so that's
something we're in the process of
filling
now information technology don't want
exactly define it but we sort of view it
as as we're computing and communications
come together and ask the question how
does that influence mechanical
engineering both practice and education
now if you look at the the spectrum
another way of sort of thinking of
information this is kind of a
progression you start with data and
assemble it in ways to make information
in principle you package information and
we pass on or help our students acquire
knowledge I guess at the top of this
food chain is wisdom so information is
down here and information technology
another way to think of it is how do we
package it and convert it into knowledge
of our students just a thought as we
think about education this is something
attributed to Benjamin Franklin but out
of a reference list and their students
are not receptacles information transfer
alone is not education education is what
remains after the information and
training have been forgotten so we do
need to convey information but we but we
certainly don't want to stop there now
in terms of my talk I think of sort of
these four facets of Emme and IT and
certainly there are many ways in which
our profession contributes to the
information technology revolution we've
heard some good examples of that just
previously the other side of that
equation is that information technology
certain in certainly will impact
mechanical engineering practice and then
there's a couple other educational
contributions as well now as a
department head when I knew that I was
going to give this talk the first thing
I'd do it sounds like the same thing
professor thomas Zuka did as you send
out an email or chat with him folks and
say I'm gonna talk about IT and ME do
you have anything you'd like me to show
and then I get about 500
so I'm going to move into that I haven't
checked this with our chairperson but
I'm gonna take a chance that you'll
stipulate that I could show you a lot of
slides of any faculty that do really
neat things related to Emmy and IT and
I'm gonna skip those and if you don't
believe me that I can do that then look
on the web afterwards and check it out
but certainly there's a lot of
contributions I believe our faculty have
made are making it have made computation
in many ways virtual sensors heat
transfer for the industry data storage
technology way for inspection handling
and alike there's certainly a large
contribution that our our school and our
faculty have made as have the MIT and
Berkeley faculty as well now in terms of
how we are implementing information
technology in our education this is some
slide that I showed yesterday I'm going
to briefly talk about these and then
really kind of switch gears that toward
the end of my presentation but we're
trying to do web enhanced web-based
courses we've done distance design teams
again technology enables that we have an
interesting project teaming business and
engineering students around some
information technology we certainly are
including advanced simulation tools in
our undergraduate courses that allows
you to do some more interesting things
and then we're certainly in the domain
of doing virtual lab experiments now in
terms of web enhanced courses we have a
number of experiments going as do you
and most of you I'm sure so we use
streaming video and PowerPoint notes and
chat rooms and frequently asked
questions and we think that is a way to
certainly leverage the faculty time and
expertise and make a better educational
experience for some of our students
we mentioned the other day about how we
use communications technology and some
information information technology for
distance design teams across schools
across countries across companies this
was a project I mentioned the other day
yesterday in the panel a joint where we
try to team business MBA students with
PhD students and and accelerate that
commercialization step into the last
couple years of a PhD project and we're
doing some virtual lab experiments as
well as our a number of you I'll skip
over these now actually for the rest of
the talk I'm going to take a little
different approach I think I won't come
up with conclusions that are startling
based on our conversation I guess you'd
say it's a different way of looking at
the rationale if you think about the
impact on education and then delivery
this is I think delivery enables mass
customization the information technology
and it's the potential in delivery
cannot can't allow something was talked
about yesterday as well we may be able
to tune our delivery to learning styles
and that's effectively mass
customization I think it also reduces
some of the repetitive aspects of
faculty-student interaction these
frequently answered question postings
that we have have been a very
interesting concept chat rooms and like
so there's some things where faculty
time is can be diverted I guess you'd
say to other types of thing and some of
the repetitive aspects of
faculty-student interaction can be taken
over by IT it increases the reach of
mediated material you know our school
has I think 18,000 alums if any of them
do dis lifelong learning I'd like him to
take it from Purdue not anywhere else
IT enables distance product realization
teams it enables this more linear
realistic perform
models in design in process I'd like to
now think about what I call some
dislocation cases in businesses so I'm
sort of changing gears here and I want
to step back and think about the impact
of IT on some business sectors and then
toward the end I'll try to bring it into
our domain of engineering education in
particular residential University
engineering education and these are some
case studies I'd like to share talk with
you a bit about Encyclopedia Brittanica
your local retailer car dealerships
insurance agents and then ask the
question about the residential
University so let's look at Encyclopedia
Brittanica now anyone that grew up in
the States I'm assuming that if you grew
up in the US you had a set of
encyclopedias on your bookshelf at your
house and I guess there's no one here
didn't have that how many one here has
bought a set of encyclopedias and say
the last 10 years I don't believe anyone
will raise their hand so that's a very
interesting case study very big business
every American home I believe that had
kids who's where their parents
envisioned that they would go to college
had a set of encyclopedias and that's
gone from a hundred percent market
penetration to zero and it all happened
just a few years back so what was going
on there well one thing is that the
information conveyed in the product or
the service / product was tied up in the
physical books so effectively we all all
American kids had about a meter of
encyclopedias in a bookshelf at home
they used a parental guilt trip as a
very effective marketing tool do you
want your kid to be behind his or her
peers No
then buy these encyclopedias we all buy
my parents bought
now what began to happen is you know not
too many years back Bill Gates went to
my guest is Bill Gates went to
Encyclopedia Britannica and said why
don't we work together and they said no
thanks and he said fine I'll just give
away encyclopedias then on CD ROMs
and that's effectively what happened
sales went to zero overnight so
interesting case study let's look at
another one your local retailer
I think I'll tie I can tie this to IT
but let's think about it basically this
is the small mom-and-pop shop they have
a relatively small selection relatively
small amount of things in stock the
proprietor carries the information
content on these products you went in
you chat with them they know what's
available what they have they know a lot
about their products you know you think
of the hardware store and there's
certainly some social value some
community in that local shop but what's
happened as you know is the larger
stores and the malls have begun to
impact that and you see they're not
totally disappeared but there's
certainly an impact on that business
sector now one of the things that you
might think about is you know why is
that well one way to think of it is as
as the malls are there in the Walmart's
basically the information available to
the consumer has increased greatly and
so we don't really rely on that
proprietor to give us information about
the products so that's one aspect
probably of what's going on think of you
were in the car dealership business and
think of the trends you know many years
ago if you think of what's happened in
the last 20 years I think you see a
trend toward greater selection with sort
of fewer stops so you think of Auto
malls where all the dealers that are
competitors are clustering together in
one place
I think certainly in in the cities I've
lived in you find single dealers that
are in now they have not only Fords but
they have GM
International cars as well so single
dealers with a wider and wider selection
of products now there is this some
people enjoy making the deal and enjoy
the face-to-face battle with the car
dealer and the information that they
tell you about there's probably some
value in physically test driving these
cars but my guess is I would not want to
be in the car dealership business
depending on walk-in sales anymore I
think the internet opens up so much
information that we don't really rely on
the car dealership for any of that we
know exactly what they pay for the cars
and we know all the cars that you can
get and when you can get them the very
last little case study I'll talk about
is sort of your local insurance agents
there's a major dislocation going on in
this business as well you might if you
think back 20 or 30 years or something I
guess you'd say your your friendly
Allstate agent your local agent was the
one that helped you if you had a loss of
a car or a flood or a tornado or hail or
something like that they came out they
helped you and there was that sort of
information let me tell you how we can
sort this out
and I think in time you've gradually
seen a bifurcation in that I don't know
you know the last time I got hit in my
car I drove it to a claim station who
looked at it my agent was never involved
now I didn't like the way the the whole
thing was handled because it turns out I
ran into somebody that had insurance
from the same company and instead of
argue about it they just blamed us both
and I didn't think that was quite right
so I called my agent and basically my
agent said well I don't have anything to
do with that you're telling you know
you're talking the wrong group I'm the
front end you need to talk to some other
division so so what's happened is that
the whole industry has been broken apart
the claims is one place if you want to
argue about how they handled your claim
you don't call your agent you call
somebody else so and I think if you read
the paper you see major changes that are
going on in these large companies and I
guess the value added is in question
what's what does that local agent
provide to you so again I think I read
something that Allstate was doing
something with a huge fraction and
effectively laying off a huge fraction
of their local agents okay so what are
the themes in this in these case studies
and I hope they relate to what we're
talking about today well all of them had
that in the beginning there were
physical aspects of the product or the
service and the information content was
integrally tied with the physical
content think about the encyclopedias
all the information was in the physical
books same with the car dealership the
information that the dealer the agent
conveys to you is tied with the fact
that you go to the shop and see the cars
or go to the hardware store and see the
see the material now the dislocation
occurs when you can split the
information content from the physical
content of the product I would say
anyone that's working in a sector where
your physical content and your
information content can be split I would
be where now what's another sector that
has exactly that potential that's us
think of a residential University well
our value-added is the education and
learning that our students extract from
the experience on campus we facilitate
it by faculty and historically sage on
the stage good lectures large classrooms
large physical plant lecture halls labs
Student Union's dorms study areas all of
that physical infrastructure that
supports the learning environment that
we think is important but here's the
question can the students can our
society separate the information content
of what we delivered from that physical
plant and if so we're in trouble so a
sobering thought maybe but not it not a
new one for you so what do we do about
that
so how does a residential university
like Purdue and like the schools that
are represented here deal with this I
think we and and it's what we're working
on is we are working very hard to define
exactly which educational experiences
are really value adding and I'm looking
for the ones where the physical and the
information content cannot be separated
and and I believe we need to focus on
those very quickly because the
University of Phoenix and other folks
are going to come after that sector of
our business where you can separate the
physical from the information content so
where is physical presence not equal to
wireless presence
whereas presence not the same as
telepresence those are the things that I
believe in a Purdue we're trying to
focus on so those activities hands-on
labs I believe are one of those now you
might argue that I can do with haptic
interfaces you might argue that I can do
virtual labs that do everything that a
hands-on lab does I think in my heart of
hearts I don't believe that now it may
be that I'm putting my head in the sand
but that's an interesting discussion
will we ever be able to do with virtual
labs what you learn when I talked
yesterday about taking a part of a
lawnmower engine and putting it back
together every piece by piece and
starting it and getting it to run we're
taking apart a washing machine
can we really replicate that with
virtual labs good question I think a lot
of the you know I think mentoring I
think the faculty to student mentoring
that relationship is one thing that you
cannot do in a distance mode the same as
you can do with physical presence
that's probably debatable you know some
folks are going to be telling the world
that's not true they're gonna be telling
the world you don't need to go you don't
need to send your child to MIT or to
Purdue they can stay at home or at least
kick them out of the house move them to
an apartment nearby but they can get
everything they need Wireless so I think
that's not true collaborative learning I
believe there's a lot of the learning
and
that involves working with other
students that's the dorm that's the
midnight discussions that I believe is a
part of our physical plant and the
physical and learning environment that
cannot really be separated from the
information content so when I think
about building a new wing on the eme
building which we're trying to do I
think about how can I make that place
the the place the one the best place in
the country and the world where this
whole educational environment can be
experience I want the students to be
fighting their parents to say send me to
Purdue because I think it's going to get
more and more competitive as time goes
on now that might be a little more
provocative but I guess the question is
what do we do with those aspects of our
we're not a business but those aspects
of our enterprise that are subject to
dislocation one approach is say we just
give those up we're gonna focus all our
energy on those few activities where we
truly provide a value that can be split
between the physical and the information
content so I'm not proposing this but
that might say let's get out of the
internet web course delivery development
turn that over to the folks that are
gonna go after that anyway and let's
spend all our time on these things you
know I want to be the supplier of choice
for the labs when all those distance
education things realize that we can't
get it across without a lab then I think
they'll be sending them to MIT and
Purdue to get that component of their
experience so I'm not exactly we're not
actually doing that we're doing a lot to
develop web courses but that would be
one approach that a business would take
you know if you see a second it's gonna
be eaten up you just spin that off and
let them fight on that battleground by
themselves and we'll focus on our core
value at it
so are you willing to answer questions
or maybe that's a piece of the
discussion for the the panel consider
what businesses consider something
called asset management
how to leverage all of these things as
opposed to disposing sanding others
because really really talk about is
surely the educational content is gonna
come from Purdue faculty and MIT faculty
so interaction we could allow that
leverage like we chatted last night have
you done any quite hit assessment of
your success not we have not in in a
scientific way we have anecdotal
evidence so for an engine we've had they
had streaming audio in order to give
people enough feedback okay so
information is metrics or
and my feeling would be you cannot do it
so my my anecdotes go along with that
though it's certainly not an unbiased
representative sample and I also know
that you know I probably biased a sample
myself and then and and who you hear
from but so I think that's an important
thing I mean to decide what the metrics
are and I thought the work we heard
yesterday from Dave Wallace I guess it
was is it's not in virtual labs but the
idea of how do you assess the
effectiveness is a very important thing
yeah the comments you made
one thing that is not there that
separates could use reason might be
scenario
[Music]
but students between students and
between professors and between all of
these people and so since much of what
we do so much in some strange but the
fact America we were sample people
together so that indeed through the
introduction endeavor we create things
that really cannot be conveyed over the
wire because it has nothing codified in
fact by the time we are ready to send
both wire it may be old knowledge so
graduates today so there's a very
important reason why schools like yours
and MIT j1 never survive and so but your
point of
someone else worry about sense meeting
existing Commission's at where the point
that
what you talking about scenario one
I was wondering your remarks on this
idea of pulling together people from
that are the leaders in certain fields
together and this is learning way to
form a degree so in other words you pull
the best from this institution that is
position and that becomes the university
well before I moved back to Purdue I was
at Arizona State and there's an
organization called the Western
Governors University and so that in fact
is trying to do exactly what you say and
the I can tell you the legislatures
believe that the scenario you laid out
can in fact happen and are moving in
that direction and I guess you'd say
competing with the universities for the
funds that would allow you to do that so
I think you know and when I said
spin-off that was you know overstated
but that's another way to look at what
you're thinking and maybe that the top
schools want to get together on that
piece of our enterprise and and do
something proactive and get ahead of the
curve and so I I've thought about that I
guess I haven't started mean I haven't
started that conversation with anyone
but I'm interested in the conversation
because I think that's something we know
a mother want to do I'm reminded a bit
of the European Union where you know
there's all these counties that each one
has a great history and so on and they
want to unite but they still want to
maintain their individuality and their
culture and so on so do you have some
comments about that
yeah I'm not I don't I don't believe it
would be an easy easy process and you
know it may be a different different
organizing group and in subsets of the
various ones I'm not sure I'm you know
recommending that or
or pushing that but I think it is
something to to think about you know and
I you know we have as I mentioned all of
us have alums who are loyal and so
certainly I'm not excited about giving
up my alumni base for continuing
learning to any of our as much as I
respect Berkeley you know that's not
something I'm excited about either so it
will be like the EU sort of thing but it
would be a long process but I think what
we need to make sure is we don't do
nothing and then find out that we're in
big trouble and can traverse a market
share proud fear decline right this year
and the Kuykendall so that may be the
way of looking at it is to try to expand
the served market and seems to be the
footprint of impact of the research
university could extend on both ends
into the high school and into the early
career then that would be a way of
looking at the student life cycle
different yeah and I think I think all
of us are working with the high schools
pushing everything down that direction
and I think we're all thinking about so
that that's a that's a good point
that's true I was kind of painting a
scenario where you'd say the residential
bodies are gonna decrease you know that
would be the worst case scenario you
know but I don't think that's probably
gonna happen I think the person students
that go to the major universities and
live there are probably still going
the residential
and the apparent
free cost
like she paid for quote distance
yeah
that ultimately
the fundamental driving force
stand up figure out of the way
get off or something you know
or or convince the world that the value
in or focus on those aspects that
clearly add value to a residential
university
well Purdue zme red enrollments been
flat for 20 years in its cap for 20
years so I guess I haven't seen the
arguments lose but I am trying to be
prepared for the fact that it's going to
get and you know a chance to speak we
should get a discussion going this
morning president Ouma zucca Provost
office so if I could ask you gentlemen
to send the stage now works all mean is
the only person who has spoken
okay so firing the programming language
of our undergraduates and if so what are
you about teaching the undergraduate
courses sophomore freshman levels in the
network's last year they were about 28
McKenna Canadian students this year
there are like over 40 students and it
is not a required wasn't uncommon so
phoniest Atlantic and they all want to
learn about technology and the student
evaluations the evaluation from the
students like that they always say that
this is something that they want to
really see the curriculum because they
feel like they are really the top notch
in the forefront of new technology and
they want to see how this is going to be
like
so one thing that of course the courses
of the venturi I cannot go into all the
specific application like terrible
products or telemedicine or this kind of
application but I do Internet the fact
that the internet now is more than just
a tool or a network to retrieve
information but it's about to control
machines to connect with physical
objects and in that course I did
tell teach them about Java programming
languages XML they'll be used in a lot
of medical databases so this time kind
of thing that that we can teach the
mechanical engine students without
giving the whole course about C++ or
object-oriented programming
so that's the answer to your question
we don't teach programming nonsense but
I think we are still requiring a course
is essentially to think about something
more like what solving what the
computation is and also I think I
believe I'm not directly involved in but
I believe that we teach also see I think
art and lower division level another
thing I think theory is a student is
interested in certain language like Java
it's a one of my colleague is giving a
new course on Java programming
application and I think he was very
surprised that he it is his first time
he's giving and it's easy went over the
enrollment limit so instead of so from a
faculty point of view whether we should
be teaching you or not certainly I think
student are interested in learning some
language aspect and I think there's a
probe arises as to some extent it listen
to customer what they want and I think
again for Emmy Department somebody
teaching Java language and getting lots
of student enrollment it's very very
good thing for us
it's one hundred one zero zero C++ yes
my name is nothing but we have from the
university of sherbrooke in Canada but I
think one of the conclusions of this
weekend's meeting is that information
technology is going to be very important
it's important now and going to be more
and more important in the future and we
we've been an adding courses piecemeal
into the curricula but what we have done
with what we have not done yet is
integrating that to the training of
mechanical engineers because in the past
we used to say that fluid and solid
would be important and now we're saying
that IT is important but have not seen
it integrated as these past subjects
have been what's what's the future of
that maybe you have some I'll make a few
comments related to teaching
instrumentation where we have the
challenge of integrating optics with
mechanics with electronics with
chemistry and also normally biology one
of the problems is certainly in those
courses we expect students to have a
basic numeric language such as Java or
basic or C++ but we also find it highly
necessary that they have some symbolic
capability but it goes way beyond that
because I'll just give you an example of
a challenge that involves multiple
disciplines imagine you have a
conducting polymer that is clear the
polymer is clear but it's also an
actuator so it's electro chemically
activated to contract and it's acting as
a lens so there you've got an issue of
needing to model normally with a
continuum model the electrical
activation of that polymer the chemistry
involved with it the fact that there's
McCann
neck's causing this material to contract
which has an optical consequence namely
that it's a lens and because the
efficiency is not a hundred percent
you've got a thermal management problem
as well so the problem is that the
existing modeling tools with a lumped
parameter or continuum tools think of
your standard finite element packages
you'll have one package that'll be
appropriate for mechanics and thermal
but normally there'll be no optics and
no electronic phenomena well then you'll
go to some electronic finite element or
continuum modeling package and it'll
perhaps include map magnetic phenomena
but not optics you go to optics and
there's no electronic so one of the
problems at the moment is there as we go
to more and more sophisticated systems
involving information manipulation as
well as energy manipulation and
transformation the existing modeling
tools are rather fractionated are not
well tied together and I see that as a
tremendous challenge to put together
very generalized modeling tools with
simulations and virtual environments and
so on can be created which go across
these different material domains if I
could make one more comment this is one
more area where similar challenges exist
in that this meant MEMS has is you know
micro electromechanical systems and has
kind of been taken over by electrical
engineer departments if you look around
right but yet MEMS is a very good
example of integrating requirements from
electrical mechanical and even optical
properties right optical man so again
you have the same challenges that Ian
was mentioning and then the question is
what do we do that what do we want our
students to do to want them to just use
natural computers says you know other
disciplines to doctors lawyers I mean we
communicate with them with emails
nowadays right is this what we only want
them to do what we want them to go
beyond and contribute to model and
contribute to or even newer even more
fundamental new advances
Christian's regarding how idea is to be
mission where's the mechanical
engineering this is very critical
questions and just a wingback me losing
a contest comment this has been really
important issues for us and the table
I think the out stain mentioned that the
a dinner moving to information in them
transforms the Norwich and finite wisdom
and that that's provides a very good
framework because we are kind of
concerning focusing animosity on the
knowledge and the wisdom part and we are
are the mainstream discipline has been
that the both end in that way but it's a
time that we need to have some new
format the representation of these
staffs in the way that pieces of input
the knowledge to be used when science
the you know time is very critical
factor we have to make very critical
design decisions overnight ecommerce is
a major driving I think doing that and
at that actually giving us the big
challenge as to you know we can't do it
slow running onto something but we had
to use these things very effectively and
I see that the traditional mechanic
engine I want to be in the prepared to
for this change years as far as the
representation the format is concerned I
don't think so very well
you know preview the point I take
personal hunter and step of the very
interesting of course it's a quote
whether you have changing clothes name
but I 2.13 one it's called advanced
instrumentation and measurement that
heavily based on simulation modeling and
connected it to a real data acquisition
which is very important apart and that's
a one form of
very important style of the
mechanical journey and I think the we
haven't a motorized that they make a
rotor in undergraduate the subject yet
but on our students have to learn these
tools and then they may find some ways
of using it for the future career
development so I think the connection is
is very obvious of them we haven't done
that but they're talking about all equal
parts and stuff but we have to look at
the issues beyond just you know you know
merchandise and the purchasing staffs
but some are important engineering level
issues it hasn't been explored yet and
that's a kind of a point that we we make
a strong connection between IT and the
mainstream a mechanical joining
software's out there it's an intriguing
thing that I thought because right now
we have the ability to integrate solid
modeling through final analysis with
some of these tools but historically
we've resisted that because there was
the feeling that that's the black box of
the honors foods to understand
fundamentals but it's clearly a reality
because that's what industry is using
and we have integrated into the
curriculum if you your point about how
the research service is then leading us
to be able to get much more into getting
a tool which combines all of a lot of
fun enough beyond what I just said is
rather intriguing and its effect on
education what we talked about earlier
about distance learning where it's very
early
with that do it was just comment well I
think that we have some enormous
challenges ahead because there's a sense
in which you could say that the easy
pickings are over and a lot of the
really interesting research and
commercial systems and the future our
systems and they're going to be drawing
upon tools and techniques from 30 units
of optics which is classically being in
physics through electronics and
mechanics and new materials and
information processing and so on and so
the problem is how do we train that the
sort of Renaissance style systems level
designer and scientists and engineers
who can handle these sorts of systems
and I think the problem is in this we
can increase the efficiency with which
learning occurs or with which
information is acquired we've got a
terrible time allocation problem and I
think we've got to make some hard
judgments as to which areas of knowledge
perhaps to be left out in order that we
progress forward I'll give it I'll give
an example all of you either in your
calculators or in your favorite computer
languages will use the basic
trigonometric functions sine coasts tan
and so on how many of you know
algorithmically how the how the that
particular function is coded in in your
favorite calculator or in your favorite
computer language could you put your
hand up then you know that the favorite
and for some of you who didn't see it
probably about 10% of individuals put
their hands up for those of you who
don't know it's normally a rational
sherry chef expansion where the
objective function is not least squares
it's a min/max criteria now very very
few student
know that now whereas 20 years ago you
were taught that when you were learning
about writing compilers for typical
languages you would know that and the
same is said for for the Fourier
transform it used to be that you you you
showed your mettle by having coded a
Fourier transform from scratch and then
having done at once you are then free to
use to plunder some package for future
use of the Fourier transform nowadays we
have to ask ourselves do we have time to
show students the elegance of setting up
your butterflies when in the Faerie
transform butterflies in a certain way
or do we have the time to expose
students to the fine detail in a
singular value decomposition algorithm
and if we do spend time on singular
value decomposition and all the details
and how that magnificent algorithm is
implemented we lose the ability to teach
some other concepts I think we've got a
challenge in terms of making these
trade-offs but I'd hope that at the same
time we don't assume that the efficiency
is constant I would hope that there are
of our using new technologies methods of
increasing efficiency and speed with
which information is acquired well
that's a very difficult thing because at
the moment there's a sense in which if I
went into my laboratory used a
multimeter which instead of having five
significant places I had none in other
words I perhaps used my own here as an
electrostatic voltmeter or something
like that you would ask me what's the
reliability of that measurement what's
the validity of that measurement one of
the signal-to-noise ratios in general we
don't ask those same questions of the
process of transmitting information we
don't have the measurements there's a
sense in which in a scientific sense
it's a very primitive you know our
measuring tools are very primitive
and you know Dave Wallace and others are
attempting to improve those tools but
the problem is that we have great
difficulty even quantifying what we mean
by something like efficiency so all I
can do is fall back to anecdotal
feelings about it but I do know that in
many of the discussions that go on about
how we allocate time to different
subject areas there's almost an implicit
assumption that the efficiency with
which information is acquired it's
constant and I don't think that's the
case I think by its it's very very clear
from the behavioral learning literature
in animals for example that you can
craft situations where the speed with
which an animal will learn a simple task
the efficiency with which they acquire
that information can be orders of
magnitude different if you set the
environment very proprietary whether or
not humans are subject to the same
principles I don't know but it just
strikes me that we have to be looking
for ways to speed up the rate with which
information is acquired
in fact following up on your point
before we have the concept for example
in the advanced instrumentation and
measurement course that as Nam was
saying before we're exposing the
students to the culture of a research
environment that by actually running a
course not an oak departmental
laboratory but in a real research
laboratory where things are being
fabricated measurements are being made
things are not working all the time as
they might in a departmental laboratory
you're exposed to this culture of
research now how do we quantify
something like that assess I think it's
very difficult but somehow it's special
and distinguishes us from what might be
transmitted across the web for example
sorry I entered interrupted you Nam
and we are really trying to measure how
much people with a intuitive knowledge
so they can use it it's not separate
transmission of them if you look at it
like that someone who has this much
knowledge will be able to add so much
given certain about the information
someone else who knows this much will be
a lot more given the same information so
that that means it's already exponential
function the only way you can measure
that is coefficient that of the
exponential function and yet we are
trying to treat this to a convenience
thing thinking that there is everybody
has acquired same increment and so what
we haven't figured out this what to eat
to the aah is what a is a TA order of
the case by period and that's why the
sort of particular the talking its
measurement of the teaching efficiency
of running efficiency because it's not a
linear function and that every student
who has different
or never knowledgebase will require
different amounts keeping the same
amount of information and that makes a
pretty radical position at is that part
of our job of course is to teach the
students very fundamental things and
there's a certain number of things that
they have to learn but part of our job
is also to teach them how to learn and I
think very often who make this mistake
where we try to pack as much information
as possibly in our lectures in the inner
syllabi and so on and what we miss then
is that the students actually get swept
by all dysentery they retain very little
on the other hand I mean if I look back
at my own background the topics that I
learned most from well topics were the
actual content was very sort of
carefully picked but not sort of
Universal but they were varied some of
the topics that were very well done very
deeply done and in addition the
instructor had the intelligence to
arouse my curiosity about the topic so
then you know in addition to whatever I
was doing if the homeworks and so on and
so forth I would also go and look
elsewhere because if you think about
things who don't have to transmit all
the information to the students
ourselves now you know books have
existed for hundreds of years and that's
where the information used to lie to to
exist and now we have the web and all
kinds of others you know cd-roms and so
on and so forth so on the other hand if
we manage to arouse the motivation of
the curiosity of the students I think we
could look at the chief better
efficiency and I think this is how this
can be done I think control is an
interesting area to watch because if I
look at my twenty five was happiest as
from student to now I think there's a
control area always evolved with
information technology and when when I
came to the United State in fact I think
I'd I have already must have quite a bit
of control theory but the first thing I
experienced I think taking a course 2.15
one that's a mighty host homework
assignment okay to check step response
okay now last transformation inverse
transformation time response and so
forth I thought I knew but the first
time when idea II got some good feeling
was with eleven sati solve the homework
problem and actually the computer
started plotting the step response so I
think there's a information technology
or use of the computer if it's using the
right way it's really enhance how the
student would be understanding we cannot
really say that okay because information
technology is there we cannot become a
slave of an information technology
everything is done by now computer
whether we don't have to teach
analytical aspect that's a total mistake
the control theory we still teach some
of the very old graphical technique
which was invented when the information
technology was not there but by some of
those techniques nearly helped us
developed good tuition into the system
engineering systems some of the even
sort people called modern control theory
there are lot of matrix involved just
when I'm watching matrix I can't follow
the theory and I can come up to that
right okay but I don't get good feeling
when I get some numerical work done and
see how that can pass certain parameter
affect the system performance
that's when ideally gets a theory theory
I am free and I understand and make it a
sort of working knowledge okay so it's
really is an important aspect
to really combine real fundamental zing
unutilized computer to really enhance
understanding
I was wearing it on the side virtual
laboratory
in the following way we talked about one
of the important things that at
university is the hands-on with
mentoring the interactions
now the virtual laboratory has a
potential to replace well I don't
personally have any evidence to the
extent that we've operationally defined
what the variables are and we have good
signal noise ratio and the measurement
techniques for acquisition of
information very direct interacting with
interaction with phenomena versus that
that you might get across in some
virtual environment however what we can
say there are certain phenomena that at
the moment the technology does not allow
for transmission transmission for
example when you take the conducting
polymer example that I gave before up to
10 to the 7 amps per square meter the
smell that occurs as it burns is not
something that it currently is
convenient to transmit across the web so
we have good tactile and for interfaces
now we have very good 3d visual
interfaces but for example the chemical
display technology is relatively
primitive so when you go across
different sensor sensory modalities that
are involved when you really got your
hands in on something you're detecting
the the moisture content and materials
you're feeling the slipperiness of
bearings and so on and so forth you're
smelling the consequence of bearings
being burnt out or conducting polymers
being overloaded these are things which
were time there will be presumably good
good ways of being able to transmit that
via a remote interface but not at them
not at the moment
so I I actually don't think that we
should make clear dichotomy between the
two
I think in many teaching scenarios he
want both running at the same time so
for example we and others in our
department are conceiving of courses
where you have wearable heads-up
displays and wearable computers so your
hands are free to interact with machine
tools and other tools and where the
display technology is in one instance
see-through so that you can see what
you're doing or when you need additional
instruction that information comes up in
that same display so I see mixtures
where real laboratory work is being
undertaken at the same time
[Music]
said I what did I work for Norman Ramsey
and friends on his cold good fun
experiments for the part of the reasons
that he actually won the Nobel Prize
three years ago and so I never took that
on laboratory course as an undergraduate
man
well I think the first semester us here
underhand I taught two point six seven
one left which was a laboratory and I
was I thought it was such a different
experience from what the real experiment
is like I mean many offense was better
because of course the techniques are
being taught in a systematic way but I
felt that it really studying the virtual
experiment right this is an actual
laboratory where you're putting stress
gauges on faces stuff like that
I thought much of the experience of
actually being out there during research
was really lost because you've been
presented the stuff if you do everything
right have happened the way they're
supposed to this is a promise even worse
with virtual realities don't most of the
experience of an experiment is sitting
there frustrated typically for months at
a time okay when you can't figure out
what's going on trying everything right
so try to think of all the things you
didn't think of in order to make things
work and and so I think that if we
actually wanted educate our students so
that they are these kind of Renaissance
people that ian was suggesting I think
that going to the point where they're in
a more more controllable and less
sensory rich environment is going in
exactly the wrong
in terms of teaching them the skills of
imagination and dealing with the real
world that they're gonna need there
could actually do something good later
on well that's about the impact on
implication of IT from one traditional
aspect of mechanical engineering which
is design and manufacturing we know that
the IP facilitate the universal and
continuous access and dissemination of
information in this case the design and
process information and that given new
life of a disciplinary concurrent
engineering or collaboration community
so I'm wondering if MIT usually
correctly forgive other institutions
have incorporated the IP into that kind
of a discipline Sanjay
[Music]
systems from a distance and also
contributes to concurrent design in my
research we're working on haptic systems
we've built a three-dimensional
versatile fully three-dimensional
mapping system actually to do two power
generation and to design objects in a
CAD system so that's really uncommon on
the fringe of IT so I think there's at
MIT but it's Stanford
there's the CDR of the Center for design
research has done a lot of work in
agents using internet agents to do
concurrent design so there's actually a
lot of work of NIT fact I would say
that's the first area where IT made an
impact is in design and manufacturing
because it was the most convenient way
to disperse information but I also
wanted to make another comment about the
question that was asked earlier about
experiments and can we get rid of
experiments and have virtual experiments
as pointed out we've had some trouble
you know you can't completely remove the
visceral experience of being present an
experiment experiment so at MIT we are
trying to find ways to do the lecture
delivery by the internet but the
experiments more physically in the lab
but one thing that the professor Mary
moist it was portable experiments which
is take home experiments so that you can
put together small kits
for example attention test specimens
that you can create at home and measure
at home
similarly there are kids that are put
together for the using 70 project in now
I'm sorry the six the in in let you
study does a project where they can
actually build electronics at home so
that may be another way to make
experiments portable and maybe address
the same question
I think
the university faculty defend ourselves
in the face of IT revolutions certainly
we dudes and some of the other graduate
programs to be replaced by that and how
we find our niche market you seems to me
that is really ill posed the question to
some extent because the technology side
is ever increasing and that's an you
pointed out the huge gap in the cost it
can't be on the other hand I I think the
we all important the issue here is it's
not the kind of stuff you know that our
kids can do because of having a large
amount of information the kids the you
know one critical case is really a
research part and I I confessed I do
have a sieve all of my students having
learning not a learning disability but
the research of disability and even MIT
student the capacity a qualify exam
having a research disability and many of
them are smart kids in the day they know
a lot and another fact and III see that
the over the past several years the
correct information every easier and the
day is wearing out every evening in
front okay I know Internet and then they
run a lot but but I know doing some
research is not kind of stuff and
sometimes I ask them put all that stuff
aside just to take a pattern pain and
just to concentrate and those students
sometimes having a super difficulty to
concentrate and then
because of the future leaders should be
able to deal with the large amount of
information yet they must be able to
concentrate on one thing but in the
course of educating at these young
people as I can see that the not IT but
the di T is better than exporting to
meant them too many piece of information
to sometimes either guess then not to
read not explore not to learn but but
information you have it's just good
enough just look at yourself trust
yourself and then think about the stuff
that we already discussed some time to
work sometimes doesn't work but I know
in my experience that we pointing the
all the important aspects because
creating something and actually
inventing something it's really
different of course
ro technologies are very essential
however that doesn't that's not that may
be some necessary condition but it's not
sufficient in manner and it's really
lacking something and then when we plan
the future university like MIT I think
we should have the kind of way no good
mechanisms in doing that to assess
assess the presentation using well
yesterday we saw a better person use the
OHP but I usually he's actually choke
talker and doesn't you know any IT
technology but just sketching in just a
few icons or a few creations so to speak
but that transmit a lot of information
that at least a kind of a basic concept
is very described by you know clicking
on the I showed that about a hundred
Bugis on us yesterday but sometimes they
said to me says Molitor is better than
mine mode so that's actually point out
this one by important things and you
know in the face of IT but we research
institution and in an educational
institution should convey to our
students and and that's really sort of I
know the joy of inventions and or
creating something better now own and
knowledge and it's I see that the kind
of stuff we share with the students is
really very much emotional component or
kind of a sense or detection the
abilities that they are pointed out and
of which are totally different addiction
from IT that I'm
I just love the the procedure we have at
MIT of having every undergrad do the
same courses initially physics math
chemistry and effectively molecular
biology I think that's a great
underpinning for almost any discipline
secondly the undergraduate research
Opportunity Program the Europe program
that I think you're perhaps referring to
where students are exposed to real
research laboratories from day one if
they choose to and I believe now correct
me if I'm wrong but that 90 percent of
our undergrads do Europe's yeah yeah so
in my laboratory we have a very strange
situation was strange for most
universities where we have the same
number of postdocs as we have PhD
students as we have master students as
we have undergrads and it turns out that
some of those undergrads can be at times
as effective as a masters or PhD student
some of those kids if you put them in
the right environment are incredibly
creative and productive and so they are
not just there to because I feel good
about having undergrads they are in fact
productive in a research sense
[Music]
if you wish it's a matter of satisfying
the needs of our customers but also
taking care that we don't bore them so
you know if the kids come in and they
already know how to program or they
already know how to use computers wise
who to bother doing that again unless
these particular gaps in their you know
in their education the way come in so
there's no doubt that universities will
evolve oh just just because of that of
course still when the kids they come in
what they don't know is they don't know
how to how to be in an environment where
everyone else is equally smart as they
are right they're coming from high
school where you know they're probably
the best in that class so you know they
come here and have to learn how to deal
with that it is not going to fix all
these things even if you think about
virtual interactions and so on but in
terms of making our job easier in using
IDT that's definitely true what you're
saying is definitely true
all right so now I think that excuse me
closing remarks and you're probably
pretty tired of hearing me talk so let
me just make them for each summarize and
put my perception of this meeting so now
let me let me do this by just talking
about something I've talked about
briefly before we have this thing - no -
seven
[Music]
yqk and we don't know who's going to be
going in the future if I call me of
course this tells me the size and the
components of things but if I look at
the power of computer actually the power
or the number of components you can put
in the place - the power is going in the
opposite direction and they look back
bro
you know you hit the three 1950
if we put our memory space right now
powered this is increasing rapidly this
is just a fad okay
along with this has come a huge increase
in our capabilities the kinds of things
that particular talking about in
mechatronics our ability you know I
would not have thought it was a better
idea
Xerox machine you know have the paper
handed off more times okay but if the
Xerox machine is a smart Xerox machine
then maybe it is and let's hope it is
because new york's machines are about
the most pokey things in the world
alright and now let me give I think that
in some sense this conference towards a
very interesting light on Moore's law
now my first graduate degree was in
history of philosophy science so let me
indulge me for a second while I take a
historical philosophical perspective on
this phenomena our conference is about
Emmy right and I tease and we heard a
lot of how mechanical engineering from
we heard some beautiful a beautiful talk
with initial one by Hopkins dr. Oceana
about how mechanical engineering had a
big effect on the information technology
revolution and I think that that this
conference has really thrown light on
that know we also we've learned even
more in fact considerably more about how
the information technology revolution
has had an effect on mechanical
engineering now you don't have to be
teaching control theory to realize that
this is a feedback loop right and so if
there's kinds of things that happen here
is that if we have okay we have the the
rate of increase
provement of information technology vit
BG is proportional to is equal to eight
times a mean all right and D and E all
righty tighty all right what happens in
this case well let me see if I can i I
think I'm really bad about doing algebra
public but I think I can do this this
says Sammy and I T as a function of time
all right
they go hasn't seen each of the square
root of a B times T right both of them
grow at this rate you know I just have
to plug this equation is the self
equation I get the second-order equation
and then I have to take the square root
letter right all right it's an
exponential explosion that in my mind is
what gives us Moore's law and Moore's
law is not not just about information
technology I think we heard all this
beautiful work from Ian Hunter from
Peters so from Jorge Vargas tothis from
but actually I could go through the list
of all the people about how other kinds
of technologies like instrumentation
technologies the precision of
information technologies is also going
down at an exponential rate all right
there's Moore's Law Moore's law is not
just a phenomenon about information
technology it's a phenomena but all
technology and what this conference is
large we've been about has been taking
advantage of all these things
so we have this exponential explosion
this is what's going on and I feel that
that the the technical parts about this
conference really Illustrated this quite
nicely
all right not that not the patent unit
Pat's on the back or anything I think it
was it's just a fact about the world
right there's not a fact about research
at MIT is a fact about technology in
general all right now then we had for me
very provocative discussions of
Education I think Alex dorm look really
really brought up the question quite
nicely
we take a software engineer and teach
them about mechanical engineering if we
want something done or we do do we take
a mechanical engineer and teach them
about software well most of the
observational evidence here is that you
take up some really smart people who are
great technologists and they're gonna
learn the software and make that happen
however we also I think have a very good
example or a very good example of an
alternative which is you take some
people who are really good at software
and you take some people are really good
at engineering and you have them
collaborate together in a team of superb
example that is the auto ID Center right
where we have a world expert on the
internet so any sue we have world
experts on creating you know
nanotechnology for tagging purposes like
George Jacobson and with Sanjay Sarma
working all working together to create a
fantastic enterprise right which would
not have been conceivable a few years
ago something where you could in
principle tag every atom in the universe
if you could find a place to stick the
tag all right
unfortunately it's hard to see tax on
atoms all right now then we have very
thoughtful set of discussions really
primarily I think from all of you
together
all right about these issues of
Education I've been very happy to I've
learned a lot from this conference not
only that I learned a lot about my
colleagues work since I never hear about
except when I go to conferences right
but but I learned a great deal about
your attitudes and thoughts about the
educational process and I was very happy
to see that there's a kind of a
conference here I mean we learned we
learned something I think it's very
important that first of all clearly as
neil was saying you know education
distance education that the potential
for information technology and education
is vast
right you could potentially have
inexpensive education for lots of lots
of people but then we got a great
presentation from Dave Wallace who you
know of it in addition to just talking
about this has done these actual
experiments which is kind of nice to see
data where he pointed out that okay
actually all right information
technology are you distance learning on
its own via the web and no just sitting
there going to lectures it's kind of
comparable all right lectures are just
the oldest form of information
transmission you know they started
receive Bologna and about a thousand
years ago and a lecture of em was they
didn't have printing presses right so
the lecture was just these the lecturer
reading a book while everybody copied it
down okay
just word-for-word now it's changed not
very much since then right that's a
2,000 year old technology essentially at
work thank God we finally are getting
something where we can enhance it and
Dave Wallace's work I think showed that
if you take information technology and
combine it with teaching put them
together you can make people do better
unfortunately however it cost five
hundred dollars per hour 500 hours per
hour per hour of lecture right it's a
lot but it's going to be very expensive
the investment is going to be worth it
in the long run because of the economies
of scale that Neil was talking about
okay so I think that you know and then
then I think Dan Berlin and I think gave
great a great talk about this I was
amazed to find the kinds of here that
the words that we've been hearing here
at MIT talking about how we're going to
combine information technology with
engineering
word for word coming out of someone from
another university with a much larger
mechanical engineering department is
that that Pakistan okay so I think that
you know I I'm willing to declare this
conference a success all right why did
we have it well clearly we wanted to
show that at MIT we're very concerned
about information technology the
department has made a lot of investment
in terms of faculty to work on it I
don't think there's any question that
information technology is going to play
a huge role in mechanical engineering in
the future as an all engineering right
it's not it's really something to debate
about and let's so let me just fight for
finish up and we're gonna be there to
see it these are exciting times to live
it let me fit just finished by thanking
folks Marian gross who's not here as a
secretary for this we I think we should
give her a hand of applause
remember Sanjay Sarma the Julius Caesar
of our triumvirate and really did all
the work for this Sonny soo my my fellow
warden either they're gone sue who who
has ordered us that fantastic clambake
last night but whose idea this was in
the first place and who came to us and
suggested that we do it and we said how
do we really want to do this but but in
the end we decide this great idea and I
think that it would never happen one day
of you so thank you now my point of view
most important all of you for coming and
giving us input we're all in this
together
even if we're competing for students and
the influence etc you know the world is
changing because of the information
technology revolution people in this
room are making a change okay
[Applause]